featured event
up as tonight
be presented boxing afternoon
fights out can't hit a thing with the
lights off can't talk heavy with a light
job
when we talk can't you hear the thing
when your lights off can't talk heavy
with a light Joe might win might lose or
my draw
ERS
in the contract off knock his contacts
out
ain't no competition in the ring of
Cypher cause I'm spitting
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
which I will serve having sipping moving
like a tire swerve out here acting bad
thank you Michael Jackson even got his
winning only homie Kevin you a phony
homie now you owe me action have em
thinking Tony Toni Toni Braxton and they
all want to talk for attention but the
fame only lasts for an instant mama got
handsome and Bradford attention imma
leave them red you can dance in
Redemption
thank you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome to
presents the featured event of the
evening
as tonight
presented
[Music]
draw
[Music]
back top haters
in the contract off knock his contacts
out you will feel mice trying to take a
Viper ain't no competition in the ring
of Cipher cause I'm spitting phenomenal
swinging fire talking
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
Redemption
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
what's good everybody
welcome to combat talk with the king the
professional fan
everybody ready
oh man we back
I just saw Gabe Rosado so we got uh one
more fight before the main event uh Gabe
just lost
I really love Gabe um
he was fighting uh Ahmed off and uh
he he looks like
he's at that stage like you know I mean
he'd been there for a minute but he's
also been turning up good fights so they
keep him in the loop uh I don't know who
he he's linked to I don't know if he's
linked to Canelo if he's linked to
um Golovkin but uh oh oh he could be
really good with Eddie Hearn and Eddie
Hearn knows that he's going to get good
rounds of work from him so
you know risotto is there so Gabe just
lost by unanimous decision uh it was a
it was a good fight I I can't take
anything from it but I don't think Gabe
won any rounds because uh he's he's at
the age where he's fighting in spots
he's not fighting you know three minutes
of every round so that that's kind of
hard you know especially right now when
he fighting younger dudes let's see
let's see what we got going on in here
yeah that's right Squad up salute salute
salute we got 20 watching that's what's
up
about 13 likes
um
foreign
who who thought that we would get here
with Canelo and Triple G uh I thought
that fight was going to be made a minute
ago oh we're getting ahead of ourselves
what y'all sipping on tonight
rum and coke you know what it is a
classic because this is supposed to be a
classic fight and they'd better turn out
some Classic results so uh rum and Coke
Classic
all right so
we have a whole bunch of fights going on
we're going to talk about those fights I
just want to know
um
what uh what everybody thinks
about this fight here
you know we we have a ton of fights
coming up for the end of the year I'm
looking at a whole bunch of fights
that's on the screen right now that's
going to be heading our way uh I think
next week we got your course Stevenson
and that's on a Friday so I'll be doing
a combat talk on a Friday uh you know
and and I really love uh Shakur
Stevenson I love how he fights I love
what he brings to the fight game so
that's next week but what what do we got
today with these two dudes that we saw
already we've seen uh 25 rounds so far
of these dudes I believe what is it no
uh 24 rounds and and today round one to
be the 25th round of these dudes these
two dudes getting it together I thought
the first fight
Golovkin won
clearly the second fight Canelo won
now these dudes is fighting for canelo's
super middleweight uh because he's he's
the Undisputed and super middleweight he
has all four belts and you know Golovkin
has three belts at middleweight they're
not fighting for his belts golovkin's
belts triple G's belts they're fighting
for canelo's four belts at uh super
middleweight so if Golovkin was to win
he would be uh he will have three belts
at middleweight
and four belt CBD unified at Super
middleweight
um
and remember when uh Canelo went up to
fight baval he was going after baval's
belt
so this this is this is a little bit of
History here but but what do y'all think
what what do we got going on here
Don Q that's what's up what's up got
that vodka and cranberry on Deck
I'm just playing Cola tonight that's
what's up Camilla by decisions plus 200
what do we think Triple G by decision
um
foreign
this one here
um
doesn't give me Vibes of a decision
fight
I think
Canelo can
his shoulder
is a little bit achy uh his knee is
definitely a little bit achy
um because of the bands and stuff that
he wears you know those uh to help you
with training to help you push you
through things
uh Triple G as rigorous as he's as he's
been
he hasn't had as many fights as Canelo
has recently so you could say that
he has more mileage on him in these last
couple of years right whereas Triple G
probably fought once or twice uh Canelo
has fought at least four to five times
you know in this period of time
so and he and he lost to the vault which
was it was a bad loss it wasn't a good
loss where he lost in a good way he lost
in in a bad way he wasn't knocked out
but he wasn't how we how we want to see
competitive uh Canelo style throughout
the fight I thought Deval took control
and was actually content with going the
distance instead of trying to knock
Canelo out so
um
I don't know I think this one kind of
favors Golovkin in the sense that his
bread and butter is power right
but power is the last thing to go in a
fighter so you would say that that that
power is always going to still be there
Canelo has power too but he has sharp
power and he punches in between shots
so I don't know man
cologne Camilla wins
yeah that's right you know Isaac
it's it's really who has more tread left
on the tire to really be serious with
you
um
he
it's who has more in the tank who wants
it more what does this really mean to to
Canelo does it mean something to Canelo
wearing the Dolce Gabbana and coming up
there in the nightgown you know
um at the weigh-in shout out to the
weigh-in both those dudes came in at
weight uh they both came in at 167. uh
Golovkin was one six seven point eight
and uh canelo's 167.4
and you know the weight limit is 168.
canelo's been at this weight longer than
Golovkin
but walk around Golovkin walks around at
probably
175 probably you know his walk around
weight right so
you got you got to think about it you
gotta think if it is is
this beneficial took a Lufkin or is it
beneficial to Canelo how much weight
does Canelo walk around with in between
fights what are we seeing here what was
the thought process when these two are
entering ring and I believe entering the
ring Canelo feels that he's at the
superior weight because he's been at
this weight longer and Golovkin this is
his his first uh attempt to go up and
wait
and
canelo's younger
um he's sharper in spots can the loftkin
is heavier-handed and more slower foot
so if uh Canelo lost any
step in his feet does it equal do they
equal in foot movement that's that's the
big thing right so we have the the one
fight right now that's uh getting ready
to go down and I'll give you the
introductions and everything to that
fight actually happening
but um they walk into the ring right now
so I just want to know your thoughts on
who you think is going to win today and
why because it can't be oh I just think
you know Triple G by decision why Why by
decision do you do you do you feel that
he's gonna outwork Canelo do you feel
like Canelo lost his step or do you feel
that Canelo will win by knockout or a
Triple G I think I we have never seen
Canelo truly hurt
we've we thought we've seen Triple G
hurt
but we've never seen Canelo truly hurt
and does he really get hurt does he get
hurt with a body shot and has has people
been trying to hurt him too much to the
Head pause and not the body and it's the
body to keep so right now we have Israel
on Gonzalez versus Jose uh Rodriguez
um
super flyweight Championship
uh you know 12 rounds
114 weight 114 is like one of my legs or
something like that or a leg and a half
or something
he got both my legs out there fighting
each other
ridiculous let me see in the nightgown
facts though if if you look at it he
came out there in the 90. he did I think
that's the most disrespectful thing that
you could do you come into a weigh-in
and you're wearing a 90. you come in
with your slippers your nightgown like
you I don't know is is it is it uh a
foreshadowing I'm gonna put you to sleep
put you to bed I have no idea he started
doing this a minute ago and I thought it
was highly disrespectful and you know
he's just lean heavy into it that it has
been part of his thing I don't know if
he has a deal with Dolce Gabbana showing
a nightwear but uh Canelo has been doing
this every way in he comes with night
gear
and I don't know if he comes with
slippers on me personally I'll come with
some Crocs on you heard Crocs and and
and and and the jock strap both
you can get on his skin
you gotta be as much as disrespectful as
possible uh you know psychological Edge
you know I don't know man but I just
find it so weird it's so disrespectful
that your man does it and then nobody
says anything about it
nobody says yo what the hell are you
doing in this nightgown but nah nah he's
outside let me see
total brother hurt Canelo oh yeah
that's right and and and and and and and
yeah and he finished kota's brother off
pause
um yeah yeah that was very early on
though but how many years ago was that
was that was like 10 years ago right nah
that I'm talking about
I'm talking about mature Canelo you
talking about pre-floyd Canelo I'm
talking about mature Canelo pre-floyd
canola I thought Floyd uh heard him with
a couple of shots but Floyd wasn't the
one that's not Pretty Boy Floyd you know
Pretty Boy Floyd would have jumped on
him pause uh but you know that was
that's money made so money made you know
takes his time you know money maze wants
to go the distance so
I know all you heard about um
Spence
and your boy Bud Crawford
supposedly uh is a real close on that
deal and the fight's supposed to be for
November 19th
that would be a hell of a birthday
present for Cog you know and my daughter
and all the Scorpio shout out to the
Scorpios
he said jeez King we got to pause your
whole convo AE yo facts though
um
that's that's that oh man that's I I
just want that fight to happen there's a
lot of fights that I want this year to
actually just just go through
like I want to see Deontay Wilder get
rid of his next fight and um move on to
fighting Andy Ruiz Jr
if they're talking about Joshua versus
uh Fury where does that leave USAC who
who does USIC fight right that leaves
usik out there to fight somebody
um does he fight Big Baby Davis
you know this Big Baby Davis I mean he's
still in the wings does he get a shot
um and then then you move on to Ryan
Garcia
does that fight happen with tank you
have Devin Haney versus camboces too you
know after that who does uh I I believe
Devin Haney wins that fight comfortably
you know um
you know who who where does that go you
know so we have a lot of fights so
Shaquille Stevenson I think is the first
Domino to fall uh next week and I'm not
not losing I mean just you know as far
as pushing the narrative forward of uh
Fighters that we want to see fight each
other so you know Shakur moves on and
fights somebody or fights to do this
fight next week
um we also have
um what what is that um
uh not Chris Eubank Jr versus uh Nigel
Ben's son uh uh Connor Ben uh that
that's supposed to be a good fight uh
kind of been is coming up two weight
classes and a weight draining uh Chris
Eubank Jr to come down to a catch weight
so I think yeah Chris Eubank Jr is going
to be uh weight during going into that
fight kind of gonna be coming up so
he'll have a lot of his power going into
that fight I think that's a lose-lose uh
proposition for
um this dude uh Chris Eubank Jr I don't
I don't think that's a a good
proposition for him but it's a good
money fight
for him you know that's that's a a
perfect money fight for him I think that
that works in his favor as far as cash
goes but he had the opportunity to fight
Triple G he had the opportunity to fight
uh Canelo he had the opportunity to
fight the chalos and he took a different
route and I don't think that route was
conducive to his growth yeah he got you
know and we're talking about Chris
Eubank Jr he got uh with Roy Jones Jr
but did that push him anywhere did that
take him to the next level and I don't
believe so I said but I believe we
started hearing less about him
since then what we got going on here I
got spins in the War of Attrition if
this is true
aha booty time yo first of all my dinner
Buddha was fantastic my my wife made
um
Chinese food so she's not Chinese she's
Dominican
um excuse me
she made uh shrimp shrimp fried rice and
she you know she has to mix it up
Dominican style so she made uh fried
tostones and uh yeah so that was
definitely popping and my son was like
oh I didn't really like the tostones and
I was like well son give me your
thoughts and uh that's how we got the
Roman Coke after that
I'll go wash down fuzzy what's going on
baby yeah Spencer War of Attrition
you've been Camp okay Ubank didn't
cancel the fight the fight isn't
canceled that actually the fight is
still is still there
I don't think they had enough interest
in the tickets
and they're trying to drum up interest
for the tickets so the fight is still
there
funds was good baby everybody everybody
I want everybody to give a round of
applause uh for my man fawns you know
funds definitely puts in that work love
everything he does you know I love his
Retro Gaming show every time I watch it
I give Vibes of me walking in the arcade
so definitely say what's up to my man
fawns and and I love the hell out of you
brother I love the hell out of you swear
to God it's one of the dudes that in our
uh Gaming Community that I am so happy
that I've met and and um
and I have an opportunity to even reach
out and talk to you know so funds is
definitely that dude he's real
you know there's a lot of fake guys out
here he's one of the real dudes who has
always been there for me and been there
for the team so give a shout out to
funds much respect thank you for
watching funds hopefully me and you can
have a drink tonight and uh watch the
fights you know
definitely everybody here so we had to
fight before the main event we got
Rodriguez versus Gonzalez and
fly weights I hate when they put fly
weights like right before like
middleweight and stuff like that but I
guess that's to get the energy in the
crowd as far as the Matchmaker go you
got to be able to
um build the crowd so they look like
they're starting off pretty good all
right so
uh I'm not gonna go uh do the fight by
um the blow by blow for this fight
because I'm Gonna Save the blow block a
little pause for Canelo versus
um
Triple G but um
let me see you said a war of attrition
somebody said a war of attrition for
Spence versus
um Crawford
I think the moment Crawford lays his
feet flat
that's when he's cooked
he has to I hope he's jogging this whole
way through and and Crawford does do a
lot of road work
um I hope he's he's not lifting too much
weights I hope he's practicing moving
for all 12 rounds
because he's going to be hunted for 12
rounds and I and I hope Crawford
works on his jab right hand or or jab
left hand depending on if he goes
softball or if he goes Orthodox I think
he's gonna go stay South Pole in this
fight I don't think he's going to go to
Orthodox I don't think that works for
him
and I think he moves the whole fight he
has to move the whole fight he has to
give uh Spence angles if he doesn't give
suspense angles and turns and pivots and
shifts and moves and uses his strength
on the inside to wrestle uh Spence
I don't think that he's going to be able
to survive that that that that that type
of fight because you know Spence is
going to place his shots the whole night
all night long he's going to place his
shots and he's not going to weigh shots
and he's not going to give too much uh
for Crawford to work with so Crawford
has to be able to make his shots he's
gonna have to be able to move dips dive
and and try to Pivot
I I do want that fight to go 12 rounds I
do want it to go 12 ounce but I think if
the moment that Crawford decides to go
flat-footed and tries to stand in front
of Spence I think that is absolutely to
his detriment that has been to the
detriment of anybody that stood in front
of Spence and if he feels that he's
going to fight Spencer's fight and and
stay in the middle of the Ring
that is to his detriment he's going to
swell him up and if he swells him up
he's he that's it and I've seen Crawford
hurt so I don't think Crawford can take
spinch's punch as much as we think that
uh Spence can take crawfish punch I
think Spence can take crawfish punch but
I don't think he can take a bunch of
them
because Spence doesn't get hit back to
back to back like Floyd Floyd get hit
with a clean shot and move and dip grab
and turn and hold you understand so he
understands when he gets hit how to duck
and how to roll
I don't know I see a really good fight
but tonight
I see two older dudes
and not saying in age
and fighting you got Canelo and Triple G
and age-wise they're fine right you got
Triple G that's 40 years old and you got
Canelo that's what like 30 30 32 34
something like that
um
but and you you have them fighting each
other
but here it seems like Fighters that are
long in the tooth that had so many
fights so and they're too comfortable
with each other they know each other too
well we would see people that really
just want to say you know what I have to
put an exclamation point on this
Golovkin feel that both of those two
fights that he was robbed
Canelo feels that in those he he's
trying to get back from the ball fight
and Canelo feels like a sense of
arrogance like this dude is still back
here I need to finish him off pulse and
get him out of there
let's see what's going on
yo
haven't had anything
nothing it's still there usually nine
times out of ten the the drinks they'll
be there to the end of the fight
I don't even nothing not at all
the craziest part about that is
the New Yorker in me and the circles
that I'm around
that pause just comes out when you hear
something suspect it's kind of crazy
it's it's wild if you got like two uh
New York Street dudes that joint just
hit like crazy
I was I'm I'm holding there I'm holding
it because I was gonna say it right
there
Fury versus AJ is
I think yeah I think Fury kills AJ to
the pause uh I don't I I don't think he
I think he he stops him
I never thought AJ had a good chin
I never did I never thought AJ had a
good chin I I thought I thought um
AJ was like a bodybuilder that they
taught how to fight and had decent
boxing skills very decent boxing field
he has better boxing skills than Deontay
Wilder what deante Wilder has is better
self-belief
better chin and more power right better
conviction of self
Fury is a real boxer fighter
to his core to his heart
he's he's he's uh he's one of those
little bad kids that you have in class
he's a menace in his in into his core
and he knows how to fight
Fury is a big man that knows how to use
his distance know how to fight on the
inside know how to be vicious
and
he understands the principles of boxing
I think Fury if he ever continued like
if he fought I told you I think the hell
he beats the hell out of usik I think
usick stands stands you know stick
around for a little bit but I think once
you get Fury going like if he's truly
motivated he feel really feels like he
has to be the Gypsy King I think Fury
actually
um can be the most dominant uh
heavyweight because remember Deontay
Wilder if Deontay Wilder gets the The
Knockout in that first fight and they
count Fury out in that first fight when
he knocks him down we don't ever get to
see how fantastic Fury can be in the
second fight and so on and so on and so
on right so you know things happen for a
reason
um you know sometimes you don't may not
like it but uh we don't get a chance to
see how the greatness of Fury laid on he
he definitely shows uh how a big dude
that doesn't have to look uh chisel like
AJ can actually hold his own you know
and be that that dude that that Fighter
um Devin camposis
what do y'all care about that fight but
do you don't want Devin Haiti to fight
tank because I wanted him to fight tank
right off the rip but that you know when
you sign a
um a rematch clause you got to go run
that back and there's no way in hell
combosis is let that money fly out the
window
he don't care if he get beat up he wants
that money so no no at no point in time
is that so I I can't wait to see that
fight
I don't think camboses can do anything
different I think Devin Haney can take a
little bit more chances and knock him
out to be honest with you I think he can
go for The Knockout in that fight he
said Fury is more loved here in the UK
than AJ
um I don't know I live in America so
um
how we view I think AJ should have went
with Floyd I think AJ
after his loss to Ruiz I think AJ should
have went and stayed at Floyd's boxing
camp
I think he's a little disillusional
um
delusional in in the sense that
he has a lot of yes men around him that
surround AJ and I think AJ needs to be
in Floyd's environment he needs to be in
a dog pound environment the dog eat dog
environment whereas it's um not saying
that he needs to be humbled I just need
he needs a grounded base reality where
he's not walking down the street where
there's a bunch of adulation you know
following him I think he needs to be in
a situation where he can walk down in uh
Nevada and nobody cares you know it's
like whatever it's a big dude that boxes
you know opposed to if he's in London
you know
um
that swamp them
you feel like a superstar
you know and and his arrogance after the
end of the fight you know to take away
that from the moment of usik we we cut
off the after we we cut off the fight
right we left after using had beat him
and we was like okay the fight is over
and we left and we didn't even get a
chance to talk about what the hell he he
just went bananas
it's it's
his reality got shattered
so if he was grounded in reality I think
he works a little bit different in those
fights to be honest with you and
sometimes you have to keep yourself in
an unstable environment in an
environment that is grounded opposed to
a sheltered environment you know stay
away from there
that's why a lot of times you know uh
Oscar De La Hoya will go train in Big
Bear he wouldn't go train in California
he would he would stay away from certain
areas where he can actually focus on
being not the celebrity but being the
the fighter you know and and he can walk
around and nobody cares of who he is so
you know when Shane and these dudes will
go away to these training camps you go
away to these training camps to take
yourself from that environment get away
from these people that that supposedly
love you and keep him giving you
thumbs up and telling you you're doing
the greatest when you're not you want
people to tell you yo
work on this your chin is whack or work
on this when Oscar found out that his
chin was whacked he got Floyd uh senior
to teach him defense so and I didn't see
AJ work on things
to change
he he needs to work on things to make
him change so
right now we're in the third round and
they doing what fly away to do
touchy touchy Punchy touchy and it
looked pretty decent I mean
we but we have for the main event we
have uh you know Triple G
I'm surprisingly
this time I'm gonna go for Triple G I
didn't like a certain things that I saw
in uh Canelo ball I didn't like
um
certain things that I saw in a lot of
the Canelo European tour that he was
going on Gathering the belts
so
I I mean
I just I don't know for some reason I
feel like Triple G is going to bring a
lot to the table I could be wrong I
could be absolutely wrong
I still think that a canola once told he
wants a quick win so he looked along and
said he said who has the biggest name
who I can make the most money with and
who I can look the best with right and
I think he chose Triple G
out of that that that grouping because
he I think he felt that Triple G was the
weakest out of the group
so
let me see
did AJ AJ did the Eight Mile ending
freestyle after yo facts
facts facts facts
so I don't know
you you gotta really think
Triple G
might have a little bit more in the tank
because he didn't have all those extra
fights and Canelo could have less in a
tank
um
because he had all those extra fights he
went on that European tour remember he
went and got all four belts but then he
also had to have the fight up there and
the first fight up there and then he
went and he fought baval so you gotta
say uh five fights right to be honest
with you in that period of time
what's going on Suicide Kings
um
and
that's that's a lot of
High Caliber
fights in a short period of time where
Triple G probably had two fights
and he got Knockouts right
so
it's just the wear and tear on it as as
you see I I really honestly believe
tonight might be triple G's night
oh might be canelo's night to to to lose
the the fight should have Canelo went
straight after baval
because before said that he would go and
fight uh Canelo for his belts at 168 he
said he'll go down to 168 and give him
the rematch so Canelo didn't take the
rematch with baval and he he opted for
Triple G because maybe he feels like the
the ball fight will be still on the
table
because baval has a fight coming up next
too and actually uh Canelo would you
fight baval if all lost and he was like
nah I wouldn't fight him same way he
said he wouldn't fight uh David
benavidez because he's not going to
fight any Mexican Fighters which I
believe is a bunch of BS
if you're a fighter you fight everybody
no I don't care to race I don't care if
we both black we're fighting you know
you're in my division we're fighting I
don't care if we're both Mexican we're
fighting I don't I don't care about that
so
that I found that to be very odd that's
that was a supreme duck like I'm I'm
just gonna duck this dude and um
we
want to see him fight these fights we
want to see him fight you know uh David
benavidez we want to see him fight the
Charlo uh you know um Jamal we want to
see him fight
um other people but we're not gonna like
like Boo Boo we we're not going to get a
chance to see these fights if he's not
willing to make these fights and if he's
still on that European tour fighting
those European upright dudes they give
him the best ability to win
and
this Triple G thing
so I think tonight
oh
biggest thing that I've heard
this is uh canelo's last fight
with the zone
tonight right
and he might be going to the PBC
if he goes to the PBC
then you might have him fight Charlo
if he wins
if he lose
does the PVC want them
and and this is the last fight with
Triple G
and the zone
so
that is a weird dynamic right because if
Triple G wins does he resigned with the
Zone but who does he fight after that
at Super middleweight right that's what
Chris Eubank Jr really screwed himself
out of her bag
who does Triple G fight next because
he's not going to go up to fight baval
and before he he I he won't fight before
all right so that's that's out of the
question because the ball is at 175. who
the hell does Triple G fight
at 168 if he beats Canelo
do we get a chance to see if part for
this does anybody want to see a part for
this
I I know damn sure I don't want to see a
part four of this
unless this is crazy unless it's a Tommy
Hearns
um Sugar Ray Leonard type of thing let
me see
Melbourne knocked out Adrian Peterson
yeah yeah
what do you experience with boxing
um I used to box
I used to box a minute ago um when I was
younger Golden Gloves uh stuff like that
and always been around boxing and boxing
circles and boxing people uh
on my whole life you know um
Superman Aaron Davis you know
that's that's that's my guy
um he's Iran Buckley uh panel Whitaker
rest in peace
um so I was always in circles always you
know sparring with people
um you know uh and stuff like that um
what is it Don King called uh Carl king
um Don King's son uh those things I used
to be at Gleason's gym all the time you
know down there I come from Fort Apache
boxing gym on Third Avenue in the Bronx
it's it's no longer there but that was
the boxing gym I was fighting out of
that's the boxing gym Hector Camacho uh
Ford out of and because of Hector
Camacho uh rest in peace um
I I went to that gym he gave me my first
uh money to pay for the gym it was it
was it was a crazy day
um he pulled up in a Ferrari I've never
sold what a Ferrari looked like at my
age and you know we watched the car
because he went to go see somebody at
Maria Lopez uh housing projects watched
the car uh he came out he was like uh
his his fifty dollars and he was like if
you meet me at the boxing gym I got more
money for you so he sped up the hill in
the car and we went chasing after him
and
um I guess the dudes I was with they you
know they stopped running and I just
kept running I just kept running kept
running and got to the boxing gym and by
the time I got to the boxing gym he was
already
um warming up
and like that was the first time I ever
seen a dude like jump rope like that the
way that Camacho jump rope and hit the
speed bag and then he was hitting the
heavy bag and he gave the guy another
fifty dollars and that I think that paid
for me for a year I gave him gave all my
money
and I think that paid for me for like a
year or something at the gym and uh
Hector Camacho was uh he was the most
magnificent person
box that I seen physically in front of
me
um so fast
lightning fast and his hands and his
feet
moved it was like God kissed this guy
and and gave him these powers and he was
just super electric super fast
anything that you see on TV
doesn't compare
to what it's like seeing that man in
person movies like trying to hold
Mercury
the guy was that slick that that fast
that elusive showed you different things
and he was
unapologetically never afraid of
anything in the ring nothing
whatever he showed you how to counter
certain things how to do things to make
people throws to certain shots like
you'll fake your shoulder throw
and the guy will toss and then he would
roll back in do a check left hook
um and heck the fort with his hands in a
posture that made it seem like he was
inviting but he wasn't he was always
prepared for whatever he was going to
throw early Hector Camacho Jr was a
fantastic fighter to watch and
impossible to to to quantify when he
fought Edwin Rosario he beat this snot
out of that Rosario but Edward Rosario
um heard him a lot in that fight
nope the fight didn't start yet
you wish I covered the KSI fight
ah
I hate gimmick fights like that he
fought two dudes in one night
that was so gimmicky man that was so oh
it was so cringe it was so cringe it was
so the only fight that I wanted to see
was FouseyTUBE because I can't stand
Fouseytube and I wanted to see fousey
get beat up that's the only fight that I
watch
I'm gonna do this Anderson Silva fight
I'm gonna do that fight I'm gonna do the
silver
um Anderson Silva uh Jake Paul fight
because I want Anderson Silva to beat
the hell out and I think it's just
something for all all to laugh about you
know I have a good time about I honestly
want Anderson Silva to beat the breaks
off him I think he's he he thinks that
uh Anderson Silva's a joke I respect
Anderson Silva I love to give Anderson
Silva my money I don't think he got paid
enough when he was in the UFC so of
course I will I will definitely uh do
that fight and and if dude's tune in and
and watch you know
cool but it's more out of pure respect
for Anderson Silva and pure disdain that
I have for Jake but I think Jake
actually brings them to the space I
think Jake is is a as a funny comedian
and you know and he's he's just like a
little bad boy that that wants to fight
so I'm down with it I'm down with it
he said let's go about time I mean y'all
into that stuff so I'll I'll cover if it
if it's good when he's gonna fight
Rockman Jr
I was going to cover it because I was
gonna I was gonna respect you know rock
my junior getting a bag I think Jake is
entertaining I don't think KSI is
Entertainer
you understand like I I don't he said we
want it all I I don't think KSI was was
entertaining I thought it was sloppy I
thought it was nasty but as funny as we
we see Jake Paul is
I honestly believe that he he does they
do put on funny but decent fights you
know him and
Nate Robinson
that was hilarious the memes that came
off of the Nate Robinson fight was
absolutely I haven't seen Nate Robinson
since
I and I know y'all probably do because
you're probably following them on on
Instagram on Twitter or whatever
I haven't seen him since and I thought
that I thought he punched his soul out
his body so I thought that was hilarious
and I need some get back I need to get
it back
but I don't I don't think I think Dennis
I'm and I call him Dennis the Menace I
think Dennis the Menace is is is gonna
just continue to do what he threw I just
hope Anderson Silva actually you know
catches him with something does
something to him
yeah he needs to be brought down he had
a few Fighters pull out
yeah y'all y'all all spot on with that I
did you know um
I didn't know who KSI was supposed to
fight see the thing with KSI is
I don't think he can sell a room
as much as Jake
I think Jake sells a room more than Luke
just to be honest with you I think he's
a pure salesman and he understands
how to sell
there's a difference between being a
great fighter you can be a great fighter
and nobody knows you I don't know how
many of y'all knows boots and it's right
and he's a phenomenal great fighter
but there's more people that know Jake
Paul and Jake Paul isn't uh and he takes
boxing seriously but he's a good seller
he gets to sell himself
more and I think at this point in time
where everybody is on social media and
everybody is on Instagram Twitter and
all this other stuff trying to sell a
self trying to chase clout trying to get
likes and stuff I honestly believe Jake
is the master of that domain and he
sells itself like no other so he can
sell out a room
I don't think he was selling well with
Rockman Jr
so they had to bring in a big name like
Anderson Silva
and it's working
everybody's interested in that fight
I would have loved to see him fight Mike
Tyson so Mike Tyson can finish him pause
yeah he knows how to get people
attention like that time when he was uh
laying down and he said that he was
being resuscitated or something or he
injured himself trying to promote the
fight I thought that was absolutely
genius but he said nurse nurse I think
we're losing him I think I think he's a
genius I think he's a genius in that
space so
yeah I'm gonna cover that fight and I
want to cover that fight I think that
fight is definitely worthy of our time
we're in round seven and uh
uh Rodriguez and Gonzalez is still in
the center of the ring and then head to
head and they're just you know pushing
on each other and um jabbing and hooking
on each other
just it's a good decent fight it's a
good decent fight but the Zone never
really gives you the best undercards
right so your undercards is always going
to be filled with
people you might know or people you
might have heard of when it's when it's
a top card all the money is going to
Canelo and Triple G
because they have to when they put a
card together you pay
right so you pay your top people and
then you pay everybody else the money
that's left over and
first of all the zone is not supposed to
be on Pay-per-view the zone is supposed
to be on uh the Zone Network that I paid
a hundred dollars for for the year
and all they told us in the beginning
that there won't be any pay-per-view
remember the Zone was supposed to be the
pay-per-view free model and this now we
have pay-per-view right and the only way
he was going to get pay-per-view that's
the only way he got Canelo in there
because Canelo commands a big purse so
you have to do pay-per-view in order to
give him the revenue in order to push
the fight forward so
like we had uh almost in round eight uh
you know this fight is probably go 12
rounds and then we're going to get to
the main event and I honestly believe
that uh this this might be triple G's
night this might be triple G's night so
highly possible and you know you got a
lot of Canelo fans that's here and
across the world that is looking for
Canelo to beat the hell out of this dude
so I don't know
I don't think out of both those fights
that uh it happened I thought they
equally fought each other very well
first fight I thought Triple G won
second fight I thought Canelo won but he
did so
third fight
somebody got to step it up somebody has
to lose a step let me see KSI sold out
uh the O2 Arena sells our music concerts
pretty sure 500k pay-per-view by as well
Jake is bigger than the us though he's
four sold out pay-per-view all I need
for my channel is TV and moves and this
will be my go-to for everything well
you are in luck sir attic and I is
working on the show that will make its
debut probably in two weeks
and um we will cover
some stuff that you're going to be
interested in it's going to be on
Mondays
um
and you will definitely uh like the show
so we're crafting the show we already
have the intro for the show
uh we already have the direction for the
show
and um we're just working on a little
extra stuff you know overlays and stuff
like that and where it's going to be
phenomenal it's going to be fun it's
going to be very good it's very
entertaining uh in the topics and stuff
will be very good so you will love it
um I think it's going to be phenomenal
and uh it's it it'll be some dope so
maybe hopefully it'll be the one thing
that you can definitely just look to you
know
he said I need this gas money
[Laughter]
let's go triple G's and I need this guy
wait wait wait so you bet on Triple G
and
what what's the what's the betting line
on Triple G right now
anybody know anybody knows what's the
betting line on Triple G for
um for what what's the what's the
batting line on Triple G by knockout
uh and and decision because that should
indicate a lot
because Vegas knows a lot of things so
the betting line should definitely
indicate well this this fight is
heating up all right Rodriguez versus
Gonzalez the fight is heating up
and you have um
Rodriguez Preston Gonzalez up against
the rope and
you know Rodriguez is
um working the midsection Gonzalez's uh
fighting off the rope and he just spun
Rodriguez
uh around so they clenched in the center
of the ring but um yeah the fight is
heating up it's looking something decent
no me and addict
yeah um we're talking about if it's
going to be a calling show
it's it it doesn't fit the format of
that see like this this show fits the
form this show shouldn't be down here
right now as soon as everything is
finished upstairs then this show this
this show was going upstairs uh to the
it's like a lounge type of room and it's
a lounge field because this is it should
be a lounge feel right this combat talk
should be a loungefield you should be
able to call in and talk to your homies
that's the field that I want that's the
move that I get like even with the
lighting I don't do the lighting uh the
same way that I do the lighting for when
I'm on IOP
all right as y'all see this is uh this
is off they they're not on my my
cabinets is not going to turn them off
um because I want the mood to feel
different so when we're doing combat
talk I want the callings I want y'all to
call in because I want to engage with
you the same way that you asked that
question I want you to call in and ask
that question
you know um I want you to just super
chat I want you to hit the the cash app
I want you to you know to talk all the
way through
okay so we got a knock down right now
and we have Gonzalez down
all right he's being counted
he looks busted up
so it's it's gonna be something good
it's gonna be something
um really good but I don't think that
show is going to be a call-in show uh
for the simple fact of how we how the
format is like the topics and stuff like
that so
no not at all so this this fight is
almost over
this dude oh he hit him low that's
that's why he dropped him
and he's whining
yeah very very just not a good shot not
a good shot at all
um
but attic and I it's just it's not me
you know um you know Kos is me uh combat
talk with the king that's me the attic
show is addict but the um the show that
attic and I gonna do
excuse me
that's us that's a colliable thing uh
we're gonna have merch for that show
new merch is coming out as well for ILP
we just talked to uh our merch Guy and
um that's
stuff looks really really good attic
worked hard on some stuff and it's some
really nice stuff coming that you guys
can could wear you're gonna see me you
know wearing a lot of the stuff it looks
incredible like takes up the whole
t-shirt type of thing it's it's very
Dynamic very different very very in your
face
it's it's it's it's very good stuff very
good stuff let me see
can we have a membership thing where we
can call in yes
where's the funds and key UFC show
coming out love attic for a combat top
card a different animals
facts though yo this is true
um
combat talk with the King and me on IOP
is different yeah this is that's the
truth like right now you get me in chill
out mode me on IOP I'm hanging out with
my friends
so I'm a beast I'm a different animal
but yeah for sure
um
let me see what's the question that you
asked
Fonz and the King me and Fonz were
supposed to be doing a UFC show it would
have been the the professional in the
office because I really don't know too
much about UFC to be honest with you I
know enough to I know a lot of the
fighters
um I know enough to know um a triangle I
know enough to know
um Mount I know enough to to know uh
side switch over positions and stuff
like that
um what Cog and them hate that I say is
being a naked joke so you know those
things right there they can't stand and
I will have to be educated on that so
let me see
okay well um Cut Above uh hustle and
motivate is it on uh attic show anymore
um
it's it's attic and as dirt is on the
show and
um what is it uh big cloud is on the
show
so yeah
we got uh then round nine right now and
you have uh Rodriguez hunting Gonzalez
he's uh switching and pivoting
shooting a jab stalking
um
Gonzalez
and it's really good this is it's very
listen it's very good work that he's
doing
is just right now I want to concentrate
on future fights that we have coming up
like who who should Ryan Garcia fight
Ryan Garcia is is the one that's out of
the loop right now and I thought him and
tank would have already signed to fight
the fight right I thought him and tank
would have had the the fight in
principle already done for these two to
fight in December why isn't happening
yet
you know we're already going to have
probably
fight of the century with bud and Spence
in November 19th why don't we end the
year
with uh tank versus uh Garcia and I
think that that's a huge way to end the
year and then you can set those those
light weights up to
um well not lightweights uh yeah
lightweights up to you know 135 uh
fighting next year because you have
lomachenko versus Haney I think that's
after if Haney wins so that's that's
that's that's a decent fight a very
decent fight I don't think lomachenko
wants Devin Haney to be honest with you
I think Devin Haney is
um one of the most skilled Fighters I
just don't think he punches hard enough
but I don't think he stepped into his
man strength yet so when he steps into
his band strength I think uh Devin Haney
could actually
turn that into something positive I
think he can actually be there he said
Ryan should
um
you said Rolo as rolly
I don't think he fights rolly they
sparred together right before remember
we saw the sparring
uh sparring is different than fighting
all right so
but I don't think Ryan Garcia fights
rolly
he should
but who does that leave tank with I
think tank doesn't have a dance partner
and I think he needs a dance partner for
the end of the year he wants to get that
bag before the end of the year is out
right and so does Ryan Garcia I think it
makes sense perfectly for these two to
fight each other to be honest with you I
think honestly
those two should definitely fight so
Ryan Garcia if you're listening and tank
if you're listening
tell your promoters you want this fight
to happen and you can do it at the end
of the year for the holiday year make it
happen you two need each other
and y'all can turn that fight into three
four look at Canelo versus Triple G
it'll turn this into three fights then I
got the bag three different times from
fighting each other YouTube can do the
same exact thing
you can turn this into uh Tommy Hearns
versus Sugar Ray Leonard you can turn
this into that thing make it happen
don't be afraid to catch a l
win
go fight lose go fight make a ton of
money
Devin Haney he's he he's a fight
lomachenko probably fight lomachenko
like two three times because that's how
top rank is gonna do it
he's already fighting comboses twice so
he's probably you know locked up into
that situation
um uh what what what's what's what's the
other kid um
oh man what is the other kid that
he just lost he lost the camboces
and he lost all the belts
my God what's the kid that lost the
Campbell since they lost all the belts
and he just came back to take over
um
Lopez
Lopez
I want to see him fight
he can fight tank
or he could fight Ryan
if he's not afraid well he went up to
140. and I think Ryan is up at 140 right
now right so
Lopez can fight uh Ryan
I don't know I don't know or or or tank
can fight lomachenko
just just make the fights for the end of
the year we have good fights that's on
deck and these dudes should be fighting
each other opposed to fighting nobody
and and I think that needs to happen I
think that needs to be
um the priority on these dudes is
locking himself into fights for the Indy
and stop protecting these these These
Hoes everybody thinks Floyd protected
his o all the way through he fought who
was available who was in front of him
he just happened to beat them all
back in the days people didn't care they
just fought
let me see I think Oscar doesn't want
Ryan to take that fight just yet I'm
with you oh yeah the Buddies so they can
fight him what happened with rolly what
does it who does your Tech stuff do you
hire someone you need someone
um my tech stuff like what Cut Above
what do you mean like uh to do overlays
and stuff like that like we have a team
you know we have graphic guard we have
dinero we have uh Sean labret
intros and stuff like that so
um
we pretty much keep uh us you know at
iron Lords we pretty much keep a tight
circle on artists and stuff that we work
with
and
um because
the bigger we are we want to give back
to everybody that helped us and those
those individuals have helped us
tremendously so anytime we do
um make anything more we go right back
hire the same people pay them whatever
more that we're able to do to to advance
and and to get them you know that super
bag I really want to get a chance
they're showing Canelo getting ready the
fight is getting ready to happen I think
we have like um one more round left
and then we on the main event what time
is it where are we at with the time yeah
I said about 11 o'clock we should be
getting ready to get over to the main
event
um Triple G door is locked right now all
right so they showed Canelo and Triple G
door is locked okay so this is the 11th
round and they're really going at it let
me see
oh like OBS stuff yeah the fight didn't
start yet it's getting ready to start
right now fight isn't over yet we got
one more fight before this I mean before
the main event I mean this one this is
the last fight before the main event so
and then the main main event is going to
go on so um like graphic God did the
overlays if you look at any of my
credits in in the beginning of the show
it tells you who did what so we have
drum star who did that beat if you love
the beat drum star did that beat if you
love the the the the rap the vocals
that's Dallas Dallas the man he did that
so um reach out to him if you need any
of that stuff OBS stuff
um graphic God graphic God him and I
talked about the vision that I have for
certain things so I send him the track I
send him the vocals then we work over
the stuff and we sit down we have a
brainstorming session and then we go
over the visuals of everything and then
um that stuff happens so uh it's it's
incredible stuff that happens and I also
I gotta go to the screen so the shirts
would be available soon the combat talk
with the King those shirts is going to
go up uh probably should be up by
probably by tomorrow or whatever I'll
definitely double check that see when
those is up but um those shirts should
be up there too
and uh Kos uh t-shirts is going to go up
as well
so and then the new show with attic and
I those shirts is going to go up too
and you guys are gonna really like those
shirts as well you know really really
nice stuff so OBS stuff is uh graphic
card and you know sometimes depending on
the overlays and stuff like that
um it's uh probably Sean labret or
dinero Panera so very well known dudes
very uh likable dudes uh use their uh
stuff uh hit them up on Twitter
fantastic dudes to work with very
professional and that's what I like the
most
this guy is back on the floor
this guy is back on the floor
complaining about a clean punch and he
got hit you know it was kind of low but
I can't stand that man just just fight
and get it over with
all right so they're back in the center
to the ring and you have uh Rodriguez
hunting Gonzalez again
he's going up for the kill
jabbing right hands
left hooks he's working Gonzalez because
Gonzalez looks like he's ready to quit
and Rodriguez is uh pouring it on right
now
he's stalking him he has him in the
corner
there's a left hook inside pushes him
off
I wish this was the 12th round already
because we have 13 seconds left in the
round
and we're going to the next round
nobody told me what was the betting line
on Triple G
versus Canelo and I gotta find out
what's the batting line because the
betting line really to tell you
what does
vacancy does Vegas see knockout or upset
or something of that nature it is is it
is it going to be
I honestly believe
that tonight might be triple G's night
it might be
and if it is
hmm
does where does Canelo go with
back-to-back losses
you don't think that's in the back of
his head right now back to back losses
because remember you know he's not
coming from winning anything he's just
coming from losing
so back-to-back losses for Canelo would
be detrimental to his brand
as as as supposedly the best in the
world well he's not the best in the
world if he took that loss he should
definitely be like ranked number eight
now
from the loss of b-ball
I need to hire him to do all my YouTube
stuff back and stuff
yeah
um graphic Dodge does really good work
um but it also depends on what you're
looking for right so I gave you three
different names of really good dudes so
we have a super chat with red on 202 two
dollar Super Chat what's your favorite
boxer to watch all the time all time now
oh
whenever I want to see the sweet science
I watch
Muhammad Ali
and I know it's kind of corny I know you
like good King everybody watches
Muhammad Ali but no
when I was young I really didn't know
what Muhammad Ali brought to to
boxing until I watched them
and I studied him and watched why he did
the Ali Shuffle
and watched why he did the pull counter
and watch why he punched to uh that had
the majority of his shots was never to
the body was always to the Head
right and he always leaned back and
moved with shots and he had a certain
Rhythm to him that offset everybody's
Rhythm they were always a half an inch
too far out of the zone
Ali didn't take a lot of punches when he
was uh Cassius Clay or early
um
Muhammad Ali
and then the next person I like to watch
um
is probably Pinel Whitaker oh my a good
friend
or Floyd Pretty Boy Floyd
I was just watching uh Pretty Boy Floyd
versus Diego Corrales the other day so
it's my thing is geared more towards
boxes and how they move
how they move in that space how they how
they interpret shots coming their way
how they see shots you know um everybody
sees shots differently a true fighter is
getting punched and he's getting punched
with his eyes open checking for the next
shot and how he's going to counter and
roll the next shot so and and I watched
that and I see that you know so those
those things intrigue me footwork
intrigues me so and I know you would say
I would like Bud over Spence I love but
I love how Bud moves I love buds uh
whole whole I think he's a savant I
think I think blood is incredible
I just think this fight is too much of a
reach for him it's too much of for a
grab him and and I like Spence I like
those guys that bring a blue collar
fighter that sits down in the middle of
the ring and gives everything like you
know fights
um and oh and Sugar Ray Robinson
I wish the fight is over I wish Sugar
Ray Robinson
had more footage
vintage Sugar Ray Robinson I wish we had
more footage on Sugar Ray Robinson
I think Sugar Ray Robinson
was the greatest fighter who ever lived
and I wish we had more footage of him
absolutely insane person to watch box
fight the
a pure animal pure animal
it appear 100 percent animal
in that ring when if he wanted to do it
he did it he had the foot speed the hand
speed the power the most complete
fighter I've ever seen
in my life that's like if God came down
and picked fighting like I I watch I
watch uh um uh what is that uh uh Baki
right and I watched those tournaments
and stuff like that right
and the kenson tournaments
and you see all those like they bring
dudes in and they Master these moves and
him I said watching him
it's like watching like a bakkie
tournament and the guy with the iron
fingers and stuff like that that dude
was so good sugary Robinson absolutely
an incredible fighter
dropping to show you some love oh what's
going on thank you brother
the man who got them horns
yes I'm ready for that cross expense yes
I am yes sir yes sir so the fight is
over and I believe that um Rodriguez
beat Gonzalez hands down all right so
and now we're going on to Triple G
versus Canelo
and uh if I said it wrong for you then
it's Canelo versus Triple G
and you know they're gonna do the whole
uh national anthem thing and then
they're gonna do the whole uh Insurance
Eye of the Tiger
and get to the fight
but um 1105 yeah I figured by the by 12
o'clock the fight should be over
excuse me
this is going to be
is it going to be worth the the price of
admission yeah
I think tonight I think tonight
anybody who paid the the the
pay-per-view money tonight I think
you're going to get your money's worth
from from
[Music]
Canelo needing this win
to Triple G wanting this win
uh I think you're going to get your
money's worth I think you're going to
see
these dudes
fighting their heart out I I think
Canelo has something to prove and I
think Triple G has something to prove so
together I think you you have the the
recipe for a tremendous fight up ahead I
really believe so I really believe
tonight we're going to see The Best of
Both Fighters I hope so
I hope so I hope so in my heart I hope
they don't come out and lay an egg I
hope they give exactly what the people
want and I and I think the people want
either a knockout
how spectacular that would be
a knockout
something that we didn't get in the
other two fights because we didn't get
to knock out another two fights we
didn't get people going down another two
fights
you know um
we just got two fights of people Trading
back and forth and not really really
hurting the other guy not putting the
other guy down
so
Jay says Jay Primo says Triple G
I mean y'all y'all could start voting
now
y'all can start voting now put those
knees on the line now
let's see what it is
I don't know man I I got Triple G in
this one today
I think I don't know how many times you
can come up to the podium and get the
short end of the stick
I think today he he he tries
the problem that I have with Triple G
is a slow feat
his slow feet
is a problem for me
and I think Canelo has the quicker feet
so if Canelo lost his step
and it can get them closer to Triple G's
feet then Triple G has a shot as I still
believe that Canelo has the quicker hand
speed and I think Canelo is more adapted
punching in between shots Triple G
always throws that looping right hand
right always throws it down looping
Canelo snapping left hook inside
snapping left hook inside you know he'll
jab snapping left hook and then the
straight right his right is straight so
uh Triple Three throws a nice jab but
that looping right hand always comes
down
I think that looping right hand gives
Canelo too much of an Avenue inside the
middle
but if if this is the opportunity
that Triple G can work the uppercuts on
the inside right and he did uh like the
last half of the second fight the second
fight I watched over I watched the last
half of it Triple G started landing
uppercuts on the inside and Canelo
started in turn doing the same thing so
if Triple G can work him with the Jab
throw the looping
overhand right and bring an uppercut
inside I think that's uh quite doable
I think the dude
um that he has training him now is
training now for Triple G because it's
not Abel Sanchez
[Music]
um
I think it's Malik something
um
I think he he brings
a different style of Triple G
so remember the last fight was Abel
Sanchez
with Triple G versus Canelo and I think
that's when he got rid of Abel Sanchez
because he didn't like the same result
right so
and Andy Reynoso Jr
is still training Canelo
right and everybody's always said that
you know Canelo needed to change Eddie
Reynoso
he's very loyal he won't change Eddie
Reynoso all right so we on to the main
event
this is the last fight
and um
this this is what we came to see
Undisputed super middleweight
championship of the world
Canelo
is the champion
so this is what we came to see you know
canelo's looking at Triple G like like
he's bread like he's food and Triple G
is looking over at Canelo like
thank you thank you so much for giving
me the the nice drama show
because that's what he calls it he calls
this his drama show this is going to be
a real fight here
two guys that aren't afraid to fight
let me show that I don't know why
they uh hid your joint there you go
can you look at a stoppage in the 10th
hope and Triple G gets the window I got
Canelo stoppage in the 10th hoping
Triple G gets the window so all right so
you got Canelo stopping Triple G in the
10th round
when's the first time you seen Triple G
down
right
we've never seen Triple G down
I've seen them hurt
I've seen I've seen shots where he's
he's got help we've believed that he got
hurt all right so
we've never seen either one of these
dudes down on the knee
we damn sure never seen him on their
back
I I need somebody to get hurt in this
fight not hurt like you know walk away
hurt I'm talking about I need somebody
to put some serious damage on the next
fighter and these dudes have not done it
yet
so
either age
or comfortability
leads y'all to believe
that a stoppage is possible
from something we haven't seen yet
and I I believe the batting lines in
Vegas would would be indicating that as
well those are impossibilities that may
not happen
do we want to see it hell yeah I want to
see either one of them take a shot and
be like oh my God and go to the knee I
want to see more drama than what we've
got and I don't want more of the same
they keep charging pay-per-view for so
so so much right now
you're looking at
probably the first fight was probably
59.99 then you're looking at the next
fight was probably another 59.99
and this fight you're looking at 200 we
don't gain these dudes right
200 plus
I want to knock out
we're demanding blood now
we're we're done we we are demanding
blood now
so they got somebody gotta leave it out
there somebody got to go in and go get
it somebody got to put they nut up a
shut up
all the way in put the cards in the
middle of the table put all those chips
in the middle of the table let's go
let's go make make somebody gotta leave
it all out somebody can't wait for
tomorrow There's No Tomorrow
somebody gotta leave it all out there
today I don't care for no decision I
don't care for oh I made it 12 rounds
somebody gotta leave it all there today
and I want to see who it is I have
Triple G and eleven what up King let's
get it that's right soul track damn
right that's right what's good with you
bro been out been so out of it I forgot
this was fighting that God bless 108
dragons but it was in the house what's
going on
100 I hope all of y'all watch runaway
dragons today he has some good topics on
today it was it was a good show so I
hope all of y'all checked in and watched
108 dragons that's my guy that's my
block brother you got bevall versus
Ramirez next and and
that's November 5th
so anybody that is uh seen before fight
when he fought Canelo if you like this
style you like how he fight next fight
is coming up November 5th with him
versus Ramirez
Ramirez is a Mexican fighter Matt Canelo
said he would never fight which is kind
of crazy
what's going on
yeah his Call of Duty stream was fire
no no we're not playing fortnite after
the fight I'll be playing fortnite with
my wife pause
I gotta get some rest tomorrow before
the podcast because tomorrow's podcast
if y'all didn't know
now Jim dance moves Ryan is gave the
king more ammo
and a lot of you dudes is gonna have
hayachi face tomorrow
boy oh boy just when you thought it was
safe to come back outside
crikey
they have left King loose we got big one
folks
and I think I'm gonna go Wrangle them in
yo tracks
let me tell you man
it's been going south for them dudes
it's been absolutely going south for
them dudes
um it is what it is
hopefully God of War comes out uh next
year so I don't have to lose this bet
but if it comes out this year
and I and I lose my knees daddy oh well
um hopefully that's a really good game I
I think I'm just gonna have to bend the
knee to my uh my PlayStation and change
my name I'm gonna lose Xbox 360 level
one I'm gonna try one more time and just
it is what it is and God bless uh I'll
change my name to something equally
disrespectful you know like Wild Buck
hmm you better not buck up on me boy
better not buck up on me
[Laughter]
got a lot of Xbox dudes in the house
right now if you're watching for show
oh my God if you're watching The Zone
jump they have a lot of my peoples up
there right now
so they they they're going through the
crowd you got Michael Buffer love
Michael Buffer I think Michael Buffer
you know is is a treasure
they're dragging it out right now all
right so I guess they have a start time
that they have to start with uh by
what uh it's 11 17 now so
I think they have a start time probably
by 11 25 11 30.
so right now they're talking about merch
and DraftKings is talking that's it
that's the sponsor for the zone and
they're getting ready to have a Triple G
come out because remember they're
fighting for Canelo belt so Canelo has
all four barrels
and they're fighting for Canelo belt and
Canelo was coming out last all right and
and it's going to be indicative on how
bad canola wants it and how soon Triple
G gets to the ring before Canelo walks
out as a lot of this stuff is Mind Games
in it and then and they're posturing
right now so they're giving you a
um pay-per-view prevent uh presents
they're giving you the spill right now
they're just showing the promo one last
time and then they're going to go into
the Triple G coming out
let me see who wins in the boxing match
between General Jim Jim and Phil I think
Phil's a real fighter
I think Phil is a real fighter don't
don't get it twisted I think Phil
Phil Phil is more like us than you think
be honest with you let me see can't wait
for ABK to be done to see Phil's next
move my PlayStation got Dusty boy this
is true I got Canelo winning dragons
bread to see you Phil's an athlete yeah
I think I think he'll Phil Phil is more
like us and that's that's not just
because I rep Xbox or that's that's not
because I gave him uh the name that I
gave him Phil Dominus Maximus Aurelia
Spencer it's it's not even that it's
just the fact that of the matter that
it's the measure of the dude he stand by
his words and he sticks by his words
um
and he's been real so a lot of dudes try
to cap and think they they got him in
the bag oh he said this and he did this
no no 95 99 of the time
you know whatever he says he does and he
sticks by it so if something changes it
changes you got Canelo bones bone slave
Cali team in the house what up whoa baby
what's going on my man bones is checking
it if if bone slave is checking it
Cali's watching and if Kelly's watching
we rocking baby that's what I'm talking
about hell yes
yo that's the hardest working man in the
business my man bone slave man love this
dude man he know I ride for him for sure
he know that oh man that's my duke
a lot of people boy a lot of people on
the check-in so there's a lot of people
up watching this fight
man oh man I think um what we got we got
uh yep it's 11 20. I think they got 11
30 check-in that's right ago P West Bay
B 100 percent
let me see Ain't No Way someone who
holds a controller like he does is
knocking out fail facts though
let me see
he could try but he'll catch
I'ma let that rock
[Laughter]
all right so they got Canelo in the back
um
he doesn't look too warm
that might be a problem you know I like
to see my Fighters warmed up before the
fight he's coming out with red and white
Canelo is
um
and then okay so now they showing
gunofka and he's getting warm
all right so he's back there he's he's
throwing his Jabs and uh working his
combination his footwork looks pretty
decent he doesn't look plotting he looks
he looks
he looks like he's not like weight
drained maybe the whole time we was
getting a weight drain uh Golovkin going
into the fights you know um
I don't know
maybe this 168 is is a problem for
Canelo because
Triple G has been fighting at 160 for so
long right and him trying to make that
weight 160. maybe sometimes he can't
make the weight maybe sometimes he could
maybe sometimes he's getting down in
weight even though he's going up to
fight Canelo and canelo's been at this
weight for at least two years right
at least by any stretch of the
imagination it could be longer but by at
least two years
and now we have Triple G Going Up To His
domain but maybe Triple G was wearing
himself down trying to get to 160 and
maybe he didn't have to do all of that
this time maybe that's because listen
that extra eight pounds you know carries
and like he said he was able to eat his
his meals and he was able to do the
stuff that he was able to do
all right so we have uh Canelo right now
now he's looking a little leveled up
Pulse
and um
he looks ready he looks ready he looks
ready I remember the second Triple G
fight I think that's when Canelo debuted
the beard and I thought somebody told
him that the beard helps him
take shots
because remember back in the days they
used to make you shave your bed before
you fought
so that you didn't have that cushion
I don't know maybe this thing something
to look out for I'm not a boxing guy but
this stream is the vibe so shout out to
King thank you brother always appreciate
the time and effort of content canelo's
too strong if he catches Triple G it's
over he caught him a couple of times the
last two fights I don't think it being
over some physique just can't work as
well as in highways that's true all good
Darth Jim calling cops and sonsfield
regions whatever reading facts
that's a fact and you know what you're
right some some sometimes
bodies can't carry that extra weight
going up so that's something for us to
look out for too
they are four years removed from the
last fight
and
a little bit older
a little bit longer in the tooth a
little bit more wear and tear
they could be tired of it as us they
could just they could just want it over
yeah so canelo's 32 years old and can
and and Triple G is 40.
Triple G is taller five ten Canelo is
five eight and Canelo has a half inch uh
reach advantage over Triple G so for
Triple G to be taller by two inches he
doesn't have the longer reaches weird
it's weird
um but again at the same time
this is going to be something to see
they have a ton of fights in between
each other 57 and 39 Kos for Canelo 42
and 37 kilo
kales for Triple G all right so we have
the principles inside the ring as far as
the announcer
um the WBC president
um we also
uh have the singers for the national
anthem that's uh in the ring so you got
the one for Kazakhstan and you have the
the one for the Mexican national anthem
that's going to be sung right now so let
me mute them so we don't get monetized
just in case you do hear anything
all right take them out
um
so yeah I can't wait oh so he's singing
the National Anthem for Kazakhstan he
has a beautiful robe on uh and this is
gonna be a fantastic thing man yo look
at the crowd they sold that Arena out
man that crowd is massive man oh my God
wow that is crazy
that is crazy that crowd is definitely
they got kill manga in the ring
shout out to kill manga making it to the
fight
he's singing
no no Triple G is not singing brother
um the guy that he got singing his
national anthem is in the ring and he
has a hell of a robe on the robe is dope
it's um like a royal deep blue with a
black fur collar with gold lace around
the outside trimmings with markings that
goes around it looks fantastic it looks
beautiful it's a beautiful Road
I mean and he's he looks like he's
singing his heart out to be honest with
you it looks really nice it looks I mean
the robe looks fantastic I'm not even
gonna lie I can't cap that's a dope bro
looks like uh my Versace robe
yeah but uh it looks it looks definitely
a fantastic role oh the back looks nice
so they show in the back of the robe
right now and he has
um
an emblem in the back it looks oh man if
y'all get a chance to check out this
robe it looks nice
looks fantastic I don't know if it's a
jacket or a robe but it's dope it's dope
definitely dope and he has the crowd
popping everybody's standing up he must
have sung I gotta watch this again
because he looked like he sung his heart
out
didn't get a chance to hear it
all right so and I guess now is the
Mexican national anthem let me see
the cartel's in the building facts you
saw that right you saw the cartel right
he said canelo's gonna conjure up the
Aztec warriors quite possibly sir quite
possibly
all right so
now they they should be singing the um
national anthem
for uh Mexico
and you have a a beautiful woman and
um very wild shoulder pads
and that suit looks nice as well
and she's singing in Mexican national
anthem right now
and I believe that um after that I think
killmonger is going to sing
um the American national anthem
yes yes yes shout out to the chat the
chat is outside man y'all y'all
definitely been rocking me all rocking
with me all the way through
that building is packed
I mean you can say whatever you want to
say about Canelo he could pack out a
hell of a Arena
he could pack a Arena Out Boy man
there's no lie that guy did not lose any
any whatchamacallit
any fandom those dudes is there
here we go boy
there's nothing like it boys nothing
like a fight man could you imagine all
those people out there to see you
just imagine that just just take it all
in if y'all actually watching the fight
and you got at least
40 000 people there just to see you
cheering you on
or the majority of those people is to
see you
wow
that that that is that is a Feeling
as the feeling that's an addiction get
addicted to it can't lead to fight
kind of crazy man this guy
this guy is something special
y'all better remember him
I better remember them because I
remember when Julio Cesar Chavez was
packing out stadiums like that and
crowds was there for him so lock that in
lock that in your brain remember these
moments remember these Warriors that's
fighting for you putting their blood
spilling their blood for you
and remember these fights
because I'm pretty sure a lot of dudes
remember Jack Johnson and remember uh
Rocky Marciano
and so we got Uncle Phil singing the
National Anthem the American national
anthem
I'm just expecting Will Smith to come
out right now
yo
this is crazy
yeah Fighters can't give it up because
they're addicted to it brother
there's there's nothing like that high
right there
you got all those people there that
adulation that praise people that
brought your T-shirt wearing your
T-shirt there for you wearing your merch
have your band is up talking about oh
man
you walking out of that that that locker
room
and those people screaming your name
cheering you on every time you throw a
punch just think about it anytime you
have got into a fight when you was a kid
and you know when you throw that punch
in the Crowd Goes Crazy
if you never had it or if you give if
you felt it if you felt that
imagine that times
forty thousand
imagine that little circle that you was
in
magnified
that's crazy I think these guys is gone
I think I think this crowd is probably
the bigger crowd that they had out of
the three fights I think
I think I don't know I gotta go back and
look but wow
that is stunning to see that is stunning
to see especially come in in the time of
Us coming from the pandemic and stuff
like that you know us coming away from
what we came through with uh people not
being Arena's Arenas packed whoa Triple
G robe looks amazing all right so he has
a royal blue and gold robe and he's
walking to the ring right now with his
trainer
and that role as dope as that other robe
looked Triple G robe looks incredible
he's walking to the ring right now and
um
a man
it's a nice roll I'm a robe dude shout
out to me
on the show I'm will probably be wearing
uh my Versace robe I don't know uh I'm
gonna pick a day that I'm gonna put that
on
I want to get the other one
let me see can you think Chavez Jr is is
senior's real son or a cartel baby per
se I'm not going there because I don't
need to be eliminated but I believe
that's his son stop that
and they all be like oh yeah fact you're
not like a real fight though it's high
and like nothing else safe for the
fighter or anything else at least that's
how they made me feel that's right Road
looks dope but making sure he looks like
it's good when he's he's making sure
that he looks good when he's horizontal
yo
it was a fool using absolutely fool he
was an absolute fool
all right so they got Triple G and they
showing him right now
throwing punches and stuff like that and
Triple G and Canelo fighting in the ring
that was back that was the second fight
they showed the first fight they showed
a second fight now they're showing the
build up to the third fight
and Triple G is making it to the ring
this is this is gonna be it this is
gonna be nice
I think this sets it off for the rest of
the year I think everybody has to step
their game up for the rest of the year
for the ending of the year I think every
Fighter for the ending of the Year needs
to
um Step that game up so bud
Spence y'all watching
they're gonna have to live up to these
expectations
this this is this is where it's at right
now
you want to pack Arenas out like this
you want to have the level of isolation
like this all right so Triple G is
coming out right now so he's walking
down the hall by itself
and it's like a tunnel with his face and
everything around it and then he comes
out out of it looks like a portal
and he's walking he's walking to the
ring he's moving pretty briskly to the
ring the the ring is really close so
it's not that far away
um from the
from the dressing rooms to be honest
with you from well from the entryway
Triple G pumps his hand goes through the
third rope
walks around the ring
takes about throws his hands up
skipping through
takes a bow to every corner and you can
tell somebody that's been to the
Olympics they greet every corner
of the Ring
you it's it's it's it's show respect
that they're taught like that to uh to
greet everyone we have 80 people
that's watching right now let's get
those likes up all right so we have
Canelo coming out right now I told you
it's going to be very indicative from
when Triple G hits the ring to win
Canelo comes right out directly and
Canelo is coming directly out right
after right what I told y'all 11 34 what
I told you that'll be in the ring they
had a mandate by by that time to be out
there so
they spaced out all the sponsors and
everything by this time
that's why they showed up promo One Last
Time right before it
all right so um canelo's coming out
uh sponsored by Hennessy
Dolce Gabbana
and his robe is
um it's like an old Aztec robe
uh longer than the Mike Tyson role uh
you know Mike Tyson used to have the
towel that he used to put on
so it's longer than that and he's uh
coming out right now so they're giving
you the Montage with Canelo
on the Jumbotron
and they're showing um first him in the
Victorious pose him with a crown on him
with the number one finger pointed up in
the air and him uh knocking out people
on his way through beating up Billy Joe
Saunders
and so on
and he said what the f you done these
past years talking about uh Triple G
told you when Canelo was on that World
Tour getting all those belts
what was Triple G doing
I told you that
told you that
now they showing him all the people that
he fought
all the punches that he land
so now
he's showing a lot of his knockouts
it's the first time I saw it it said
ring walk served up by Hennessy crazy
all right so he has the mariachi band
and that's a big mariachi band
um
they're all in gold
and the the is playing his music as he
comes out
and he has a singer that's in the portal
singing walking down
first before him
so older gentleman and all black the
other Mariachi dudes is wearing gold
and um this guy has his hair slicked
back with all black and silver
highlights
like buckles and stuff like that on his
um on his attire
so the mariachi band is above the portal
where Canelo would be coming out so now
Canelo is inside the portal with the
singer
and he's bouncing he's wearing his robe
Dolce Gabbana robe
um
and it's in the colors of the Mexican
um
flag
it's the red green and white
and the Canelo Alvarez logo is in silver
sequence on the front of it
then setting off uh sparkles
and he's standing there with the singer
while he's ready
yeah Mexican Independence Day was um
was yesterday I believe
so canelo's coming through now
he's warming up as he's walking
so remember when I told you Triple G was
walking to the ring very briskly right
canelo's taking a leisurely approach to
the ring
hmm
I always know the eagerness of the
fighter
is how eager they are to get to that
ring
right
hmm
that doesn't look as eager
as I would like
and this is the moment you start to
extrapolate little things and try to
figure out stuff to see if you're gonna
win if you're going to win your bet
canelo's on the corner I think we know
so it's holding the Rope up and Canelo
does the double BOB through
and he's in the ring
praising one corner let's see if he goes
to the next praise him next corner
okay
praising the third corner
and going to the fourth corner to praise
the fourth corner
there you go
he says what's up to kill monger
what up Eagles fan
that we wake up at it attic is up that's
my dope
taking a shot of Fireball
shout out to my boy whiskey
God bless the death
anytime anybody says Fireball that was
his drink
oh here we go
man
oh man
Triple G looks a little bit angry
it looks a little bit angry
oh does he feel like he's overlooked
hmm
nice robe though
it's a dope Road
attic said you never catch me watching
some boxing that's just so that's my
dude
all right we got 81 in here let's let's
get those likes up let's get those likes
up if you watch him please let's support
let's get those likes up
Triple G looks a little bit off in the
face
I don't know
I don't know he looks angry or something
looks angry
looks angry I like Angry Angry is good
for me
oh Dave Moretti is one of David
Sutherland and Steve Westfield all right
so we have good referees here right
and Russell Mora Russell Moore is
the referee in the ring hmm I don't
think I would have did Russell Moore I
don't I don't really like Russell Moore
too much
um
but again
let's go so they're announcing them
they're saying let's get ready
so I guess they're gonna start the fight
by at least 11 45.
this is ridiculous
yeah yeah yeah the fight starts now
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go
all right
so
give you a little bit of noise
so you can actually hear that a little
bit a little bit of noise a little
background a little background don't
hurt nobody
all right
there we go 42 and one with one uh draw
with 37 Kos
so 42 one lost one draw and 37 Kos
that's Gennady Triple G Golovkin
whoo Baby
Woo baby
let's get ready to get it
got two Gladiators getting ready to get
it on
and mix it up this is exactly what we've
been waiting for
I don't care man signed a fight get in
the fight get the way in the weigh-in
was good
excuse me
they made it here
let's see what they got
whoo
I still get butterflies before fights
isn't that weird all the fights that
I've seen in my life I still get
butterflies between fights right before
fights
especially fights I want to see
especially fights I want to say I get
those butterflies
all right so you got Canelo
looking very limber
let me see if we got that thing on his
knee
because I think he should uh canelo's
record is 57 and two with two draws and
39 Kos
so the first loss is by Floyd second
losses by before
first draw is by
um
Triple G I forgot who was the second
draw anybody knows who's the second
drawer that Canelo got uh besides the
first draw with Triple G I don't know
who was the second drawer who's the
second drawer that he got that's weird
it's weird that I don't remember
but here we go
there we go they're about to clear this
ring out get everybody out of this ring
Alvarez let's go let's go
this is now or never right now guys so
if you pick Canelo
you better not buck up boy
pick Triple G
-haw let's go
all right
they're standing in the middle of the
Ring
Triple G is looking at him intently
Triple G looks huge right now for some
damn reason
wow
he looks
huge
all right let's go okay
let's see
let's see
can all those shoulders look a little
bit smaller
all right that's still boxing they
didn't
um it's still bouncing in the corner
they didn't hit the ring at the Bell
and
let's go
all right
then the center of the Ring posturing
all right so who's gonna take the lead
Triple G throws the first jab canola
counters with another jab Canelo tries
to throw a left hook Triple Three Triple
G that was a jab
um
I don't know if I'm gonna say Triple G
or I'm going to say Golovkin probably
gonna say Golovkin I'll often throws a
jab then Ascend to the ring Golovkin tap
somebody Jab
can no one throws out a jab throws a
right to the hip
still in the center to the ring
Triple Three throws a jab
gotta use get used to saying Golovkin
The Loft can throw the jab okay now
throws a hook
all the punches that I'm talking about
is the punches that land
okay Jabs from Triple G
I'm probably gonna say something
Jabs from Triple G
and uh Canelo throws the first
combination steps in with a left hook
that actually lands he throws a left
hook tries to land the right hand the
right hand misses from Canelo
Triple G is just throwing Jabs no power
shots as of yet Canelo is the most
limber and loose of the two
Triple G is just throwing Jabs
so far
so Canelo is more adapted throwing his
right hand he hit Triple G on the hip
again with a right hand
so Canelo is bouncing he's on his toes
he's doing more of the leading Triple G
is taking
a submissive role
he's jabbing no right hand
all right he throws right hand finally
hits nothing
jabbing
Canelo stepping and jabbing in trying to
land the right hand
so Canelo is close he's dipping and he's
moving a lot of head movement a lot of
waist movement I wonder know when that
stops
what does he become does he become a
stationary Target or what we got 35
seconds left in round number one that
was quick
that this round was over
so Triple G is back with the Jabs Canelo
is leading in stalking
Triple G again I told you he's in a
submissive mode he's backing up giving
ground to Canelo
he's not pushing it Forward 10 seconds
left and around
Canelo is still standing there posturing
okay round over I give that round to
Canelo I think Canelo actually pushed
the pace of the round I think he was
leading more than he was following he
was throwing he was more Adept to throw
the right hand where Triple G was just
defensive and he was giving ground so he
was in a submissive position where he
was just jabbing not throwing his
overhand right and he was giving too
much ground to Canelo I believe Canelo
definitely took round number one to be
honest with you it wasn't a lot of
things landed but it was the fact that
Canelo was pushing the pace so he was uh
ring generalship he was leading
um he was being aggressive and to be
honest I think he landed the more uh
punches and so he landed the the better
combinations in that round so round two
was getting ready to start right now
shout out to Dave Chappelle shout out to
Joe Rogan sitting next to each other and
shout out to the big guy that's next to
them that's happy as hell
all right here we go
okay
so Triple G
um
definitely needs to start off stronger
he's throwing the Jab
and Canelo does a sweeping left hook
and I'm telling you Canelo looks like
the looser of the two
so far and Triple G looks the most
tentative out of the two
Canelo wants to mix it up more so Triple
G is throwing the Jab
he tried a right hand right now
and it's not with any conviction you
understand
so all right so your Jabs can no longer
come through
and Canelo takes that Jab
so Triple G is mixing the punches uh
Canelo is throwing left hooks
and right hands but they're missing
all right so
right now Canelo is innocent to the ring
Triple G is landing Canelo is trying to
go over the top with the right hand
again Triple G is taking back steps
wow Canelo is pushing the pace
Triple G is jabbing
and Canelo is
moving from side to side waist all right
so Triple G does a one two three hit
Canelo on the body
and Canelo goes right back to the jab
looks very loose
and stalking nice good Jabs going
through
and he's trying to left hook but the
left hook keeps missing from Canelo
shooting the Jab
Triple G shoots the Jab
has an open guard
and shoots the jab now Triple G is
taking the lead role
and he hits uh Canelo with a left hook
all right and Canelo hits him with a
left hook to the body uh and a right
hand over the top
all right
here we go Triple G back to the Jab
and Canelo took back the lead position
as far as pushing the pace
all right
29 seconds left and around these rounds
are flying by
all right overhand right by Canelo
and uh Triple G is back to the Jab
and he throws a right hand to the body
all right 10 seconds left
Triple G is pushing the pace
all right so round number two I gotta
give that to Triple G I thought Triple G
uh did a lot more than he was doing in
the first round and uh I think Canelo
missed a lot of his good shots that he
had available those shots were there but
he just inches off so probably by the
third round those those shots that he's
missing he can capitalize on uh Triple G
himself was just Landing the jab Landing
the right hand staying exactly where he
should stay and he landed a left hook
that was inside that round uh Canelo
landed an overhand right
and I like I said I believe honestly uh
there won one uh going into round number
three so they showed the left hook that
uh Canelo landed it was a leaping left
hook
um but you know Triple G lands the left
hook the same way on canelo's air
uh so you know basically trading left
hook
we got Steph Curry that's inside the
ring I mean that's it's on outside the
ring
probably third row
so round number three they're back in
the center of the Ring canola tries a
leap and left hook
and then the center of the Ring all
right so Canelo is pushing pace
so Canelo uh threw a left hook and a
right hand to the body
uh Triple G is back to Jabs
all right
and I really expected these dudes to
sell out but um they're not all right
left hook from Canelo off of uh a jab
from Triple G left hook from Canelo
Triple G grabs he had a Triple G close
to the ropes I think okay left hook from
Canelo canelo's pushing Triple G back up
against the ropes
all right Canelo is pushing pace
so I think uh Canelo is
seizing the opportunity now
Triple G is back to jabbing
all right
and I think
Triple G is learning a little bit more
from Canelo that he has learned a lot
since the last time they fought
very loose with his jab very quick with
the right hand over the top so
triple G's back to his jab Cano through
a one two three hit the one Mr two and a
three back to the jab and it sent to the
ring both of them are incent to the ring
right now
so you want Triple G or Canelo to take
the lead to push somebody to the back of
the ropes
to The Backs to the ropes
all right so you had uh Canelo land uh
well through a full punch combination
but landed the fourth shot which was
overhand right
so
Triple G is pushing them back and Canelo
throws a triple jab the push back uh
Triple G
so
again very very slow starts right here
right hand from uh Triple G
Canelo slides in and throws a left hook
we see
right now they're posturing
Canelo throws a jab a sliding left hook
to get off against chest uh 32 minutes I
mean 32 seconds left and around
32 minutes
all right
canola lands a hook off again Hawkins
Jab
oh good straight writing uh straight jab
from Canelo
pop uh triple G's head back
again here we go in the center then
Golovkin throws a right hand 10 seconds
left in the round they're just jabbing
each other
nobody's taking control
gotta give that round to Canelo Arthur
Canelo was the aggressor when the round
started and I think he stayed aggressor
throughout he slipped a lot of punches
through a lot of left hooks through a
lot of right hands and then Triple G
went back to his turtling went back to
his shell
went back to his jabbing and going to
the right hand he's playing it too safe
and before he knows it that this fight
is going to be in round 12 and or round
10 and he's not going to be able to
fight back
he needs to amount to attack now
somebody has to be willing to get
knocked out and nobody's willing to get
knocked out
yeah
uh I don't think he's tagging the hell
out of him
I think honestly they're just taking
what they see available
um
it's
is it a bit disappointing for two people
that have been in the ring with each
other for so long yeah
all right round four
back in the center of the Ring again
all right so
Triple G steps in
and Canelo steps in with a jab left hook
Triple G back to the job
all right so
back to Jabs all right jab left hook
from Canelo pushing Golovkin back
and Golovkin goes right back to his Jab
left hook from Canelo
Triple G tries the right hand
left hook from Canelo
and then back in the center of the Ring
again
a lot of foot movement a lot of
placement
all right Jabs from Triple G
left hook from Triple G right hand from
Canelo right hand to the body
of Canelo I mean of Triple G from Canelo
Triple G chizer one two misses
Canelo keeps hitting him on his side
with the right hook
right hand over the top from Canelo
I don't want a left hook right hand
Canelo hit him another left hook
so far Canelo was winning this round and
got a minute 36 left
in the round
and Gennady is content with Landing Jabs
all right right hand from Golovkin
and the fight hasn't okay left hook from
Canelo
there we go right hand from Canelo
Canelo is winning this round handily
you know Triple G is
not doing enough to win anything in this
round is a minute left and around
Triple G is landing Jabs like I said
again Jabs and canelo's Landing Jabs as
well but
he's putting more behind it
all right so Triple G throws and he
missed everything he just threw he'd do
a jab or right hand a left hook he
missed all of it
right back to a jab
Canelo slide in there with the job we
have 30 seconds left and around
all right
all right you know the lines are
overhand right
strong Jabs from Canelo
all right and we back to
jabbing
back to the jabbing
triple G's turtling up
wow Canelo is doing majority of the work
three rounds to one Canelo is definitely
winning this three rounds to one handily
um can uh Triple G doesn't seem willing
to engage willing to walk through the
fire and all his lands and shots and he
needs to engage at some point in time uh
Canelo looks like the mole willing to
engage
um oh Jonathan Banks is a trainer not
Malik sorry about that
um Jonathan Banks is a triple D shayner
and
he's Triple G is not pushing any Pace at
all and there's no urgency in this
corner and it should be urgency in this
corner
I think father time is getting to him
the dance around boxing for 11 rounds
the last 20 seconds yeah yeah yeah not
seeing the right hand from Triple G
enough needs to let it fly yeah I think
at this point in time we might have to
be concerned with Triple G
um with age catching up to him because
Canelo is willing to stay in the pocket
and land these shots
all right so round number five here we
go
Triple G needs to step it up Canelo is
taking full command of this fight and
he's fighting it at his Pace at his
space at his time
and Triple G needs to stop it all right
triple Jab
he's been like the jab man
and Canelo can just double jab him and
walk him back get him off his pivot see
all right so Canelo is pressing the pace
stepping in double jab right hands
jab double jab right hands Canelo whites
he's done this double jab right hands
three times he's done this Triple G oh
inside uppercut from Canelo
strong jab from Canelo
right hand he's stalking Triple G
he's walking Triple G down
left hook to Triple G
and he's stepping in right hand the
Triple G
Triple G is not mounting any offense
back to stop Canelo Canelo is just
walking over him left hook from Canelo
right hand from Canelo
so
Canelo is continuing to double jab right
hand tactic
and it's actually working to perfection
all right Triple G does uh one two
but again it's it's ill effective until
you mount a decent offense
good job
Canelo is given a lot of faints a lot of
heavy movement right hand by Canelo he
keeps hitting Triple G on his hip
and he complains to the referee had a
minute left in the round
Triple G lands a left hook
all right so Canelo
Triple G is throwing a one two
getting a little standing there with his
hands in high guard
and Triple G is not even taking
advantage of this
left hook from Canelo out of high guard
and he punches Triple G on his hip
and Triple G stumbles
freaking shame this is the absolute
shame oh smooth right hand from Canelo
that's a beautiful right hand oh left
hook from Canelo all right now this is
how you step up in the fight yeah it's
Triple G shook
all right
canelo's back to the Jab
oh
Man 10 seconds left
rounds over
Canelo won another round so you have six
rounds
to one in my opinion
and yeah Triple G looks old it looks
slow it looks tired he looks like he
doesn't have it he looks like he's gun
shy it looks like he doesn't want to
engage looks like he's there to pick up
a check he looks like uh he's waiting
for Canelo to drop the Anvil on top of
his head he's he's is he standing around
waiting for a bus and the bus is going
to come in as the right hand
the right hand is going to take them out
because Canelo is throwing the right
hand with impunity he doesn't care
you know
just really doesn't look good if you're
a Triple G fan
hmm it does look like Canelo can keep
this pace all night and you might
possibly be right that Triple G does
weave into a right hand that's highly
possible I mean I see these things but
what I what I truly see is Triple G is
flat-footed
and Canelo is loose
well you know
um
Triple G is trying to mount the offense
but he looks spent like I don't know
like he over trained or something I
don't know he looks he looks old he
looks finished
it looks like he doesn't have anything
now
all right so Triple G tries Atlanta one
two three and misses everything
uh Canelo is stalking him
overhand right from uh Canelo because
it's Triple G
canelo's back to the jab back to
stalking him
I think just Canelo should just say the
hell with it and just take him out
all right
and
they're back in the center of the Ring
and Triple G is trying to show some
defense while Canelo is pure offense
pure offense
instead he's standing there with high
guard he's bopping from left to right
and Canelo throws it um triple D throws
a jab and Canelo catches him to the body
I think that hurt Triple G
Canelo is letting these punches rip
you know
um absolutely insane
be honest with you
and triple D is just jabbing
it's like
his only defensive mechanism you're not
going to win this fight by just jabbing
and Canelo is uh tracking him
Canelo keeps punching him to the hip
with that right hand
and nice jab from Canelo on the center
of the Ring
good job again Triple G comes with a jab
Canelo goes to the left to the body left
hook to the body
Triple G goes to a jab short right hand
jab again
short uppercut
through Jabs
you have 40 seconds left in this round
and Triple G
is not coming alive Canelo comes with a
left hook to the body
Triple G steps back
and Triple G is weaving while canetto
dances around him with a left hook and
Jabs
we got uh
10 seconds left in the round
Jabs by uh Triple G
back in the center of the Ring
honestly
again
you can't give too much praise to Canelo
Canelo is doing everything to get this
man to throw some punches he's standing
there in high guard without throwing any
shots looking for Golovkin to give him
something to work off of and Golovkin
has given him nothing he's giving him
Jabs very light right hands nothing to
actually push Pace or inflict any damage
while Canelo is throwing left hooks
right hands he keeps throwing a right
hand to the hip area
to to stick that leg down in the ground
because like once the leg gets numb
again you can't really move
um from that position to be honest with
you so excuse me very strategic he's
punching the bicep he's punching the uh
the hip of Golovkin
and he's keeping them stuck but Golovkin
is not pushing any Pace it's not like
this guy is actually trying to win this
fight
and and this is ridiculous
you say it's his most active round but
how active is that
all right so
they go
Canelo throws a right hand off the rip
it's blocked
and all right Triple G trying to land
some shots
Canelo throws a right hand and the left
hook catches Triple G and an uppercut
catches Triple G right hand off the rip
catches Triple G uppercut right in the
middle Golovkin holds center of the Ring
all right
Canelo throws right hand
all right
left hook
there we go Canelo is now putting in
that work to knock out Triple G and we
might get a knockout in this fight
Triple G is throwing a left hook oh up a
cut left hook from Canelo
very good work right now from Canelo
triple G's throwing a jab
Canelo steps in with his Jab
all right so
Triple G jabbing Canelo stepping through
with his jab see there's a difference
when Triple G jab and Canelo Jabs
Canelo Jabs with intent Triple G Jabs
with defense
right hand from Triple G jab from Canelo
back in the center of the Ring
right so we're looking at both of them
right now right
back in the center of the Ring
Triple G doing defensive Jabs canelo's
pushing the pace
and I just need him to do one offensive
Supreme push
to actually take out Canal oh smooth
right hand from Canelo on the side of uh
golovkin's head I think that did some
type of damage
all right
straight right straight jab from Canelo
and Triple G back to jab left hook from
Canelo
back to the center to the ring
this is sort of this is so disheartening
he expected um more expected them to lay
it all out or one of them to at least uh
come fight harder
back to jabbing
and then send to the ring
we got 30 seconds left
in this round
Triple G tries a left hook uppercut
and Canelo goes right to his jab and is
a forceful Jab
like I said it's a jab with intent
and again oh right hand from Canelo
all right so we have 10 seconds left in
this round
Canelo right back to the jab and Triple
G tries to step forward but Canelo
throws a one two three
and again back to the corners Canelo is
winning these rounds off of purely just
being active just being the more active
fighter and it's not like he has done
anything to look out for from uh Triple
G Triple G is not mounting an offense
that is conducive to winning
he's mounting a defense that is
conducive to not getting knocked out
that's it he's putting up a a good
enough fight so that he doesn't get
knocked out and you would think after
these people have taken 200 from each
and every last one of us because I'm
pretty sure we all while I've watched
every last one of these fights
that they will lay it out
at least Triple G will come to either
get down or lay down
and this is this is not it
this is not it Canelo is though
can't take nothing away from Canelo
Canelo is putting it all on the line
that's right father time is looking
undefeated
and looks like Triple G has ran into
that brick wall called father time
okay oh okay so Canelo comes out and
he's swinging double jab overhand right
hand
Triple G
gets hit by a left hook from Canelo
Canelo does a short left hook double jab
short left hook
canelo's working Triple G is throwing
Jabs
on her right hand from Canelo
Triple G all right left hook from uh
Triple G
they just broke him up from from a
clinch
left hook from Canelo
oh right hand from Canelo beautiful
stuff oh right uppercut from Canelo oh
my God
that was fantastic
they're back in the center of the Ring
Triple G is again
fake Jabs
and they'll got to go back to work go
back to work gotta go back to work
Triple G
is not going to do any work go back to
work
right hand
jab right hand from Triple G canelo's
throwing the more power shots overhand
right Miss
right hand to the hip left hook both of
them land to the left hook
at the same time back in the center to
the ring Canelo throws the double jab
right hand to the body
back in the center oh
left hook right hand Canelo is
hitting Triple G to both sides of his
body
all right
nobody wants to throw a punch in the
center of the Ring
Canelo doves double jab right hand
what is going on right here
Triple G is in punching range but is
scared to let his punches go
oh beautiful left hook from Canelo oh
beautiful right hand left hook
oh one two from Canelo this is probably
one of his most dominant rounds
this is ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous all right Golovkin
through a one
double jab and right uppercut
all right Golovkin is finally putting
pressure
all right one two three from Golovkin
and Canelo lands an overhand right and
backs them up out of that situation
left foot from Canelo
10 seconds left in the round
all right
golovkin's most active round
but that comes and that was only in the
last 20 seconds
so you got to say the beginning of that
round was canelo's active round again
and then canel and and Golovkin comes in
the last 20 seconds of the round and
gives his uh best performance of the
night so far right
I have no idea did he sweat off those
last eight pounds so far
I I don't know and somebody said earlier
some Fighters don't carry the weight
going up
yeah he needs to invoke Kratos at the
end of it I mean at some point in time
because Canelo is invoking somebody
you better be bold to the great he
better do something
all right here they go
round number nine would you believe this
round number nine I told y'all ain't
seen no knockdowns yet well I ain't seen
no knock Downs another two fights
I don't know
oh okay canelo's coming through with a
one two three
all right Golovkin is fighting now
somebody must have gave him a Red Bull
all right he's throwing punches now
all right so he doesn't want to hold he
wants to throw punches now and Canelo is
right there throwing punches with him
and then the center of the Ring now they
hold him
all right let's go
left hook from Canelo jab jab from
Triple G right hand from Canelo
oh nice uppercut from Canelo canelo's
the one that's Landing up against oh
overhand right from Canelo Canelo looks
like he's getting upset all right nice
jab from Canelo
oh
double left hook from Canelo
jab from Golovkin
nice jab from Canelo
uh why are you breaking them up move out
of the way ref come on now
let's go let's go
come on come on come on come on come on
come on get out of the way
wasting time
wasn't nothing egregious let's go let's
go
left hook from Canelo
overhand right from Triple G
oh one two from Canelo one two from
Triple G all right the fight is heating
up now oh Canelo tried to land that
overhand right Triple G oh here we go
Triple G landed a left hook on Canelo
okay
oh uh Canelo landed a one two right hand
oh left hook from Canelo
all right
oh Jab from Triple G right hand from
Canelo
Triple G Jab
double jab from Canelo
they're back in the center of the Ring
all right
Triple G
is throwing the right hand
all right Canelo Triple G is stalking oh
overhand right from Triple G
okay
all right oh left hook from Triple G
right hand from Triple G
he has Canelo up against the ropes
20 seconds left in the round
Canal oh oh left hook right hand Canelo
jab from Triple G oh my God here we go
now we're heating up this is what we
talking about okay here we go uh Triple
G is actually working Canelo is working
too baby let's go one two from Triple G
oh he's stepping on him what's going on
round stops all right 10 seconds to the
round
man that was a hard round to come uh to
to score oh my God canelo's Alpha blood
is right but Triple G was working I
think Triple G put in more work in the
beginning of the round in the middle of
the round but I think Canelo was more
effective uh do we give Triple G around
just off of GP do we get does he have
two rounds now and then and Canelo you
know still has his rounds I don't know
I can't call it but I'm gonna tell you
this I would have rather been Canelo
than I would have rather been Triple G
in that round because Canelo landed the
hardest shots so uh again like that
uppercut right there that right hand he
can't forget the work that Canelo put in
and Canelo put in a ton of work but
Triple G started working we wanted to
see him work right we wanted to see him
give more and right now he gave a little
bit more but who had more in the tank
right there Gotta Give it to Canelo man
that Ginger dough is crazy
all right they back to the center of the
Ring Canelo lets the left hook rip off
his hip he is not playing Triple G is
right back at it throwing Jabs oh
canelo's one two Triple G throws the jab
Canelo goes right back at it there we go
canelo's at this oh left hook from
Canelo there we go Triple G with the jab
Canelo steps in Canelo throws a 1-2 and
he's backing up Triple G Triple G is
standing right here trying to meet him
with the fight that's right nice jab
from Canelo canelo's definitely in the
pocket oh left hook from Canelo oh right
here from Triple G these dudes is
definitely giving you everything that
you're looking for 100 they squeeze and
hug each other in the middle of the ring
this is what I'm talking about fantastic
stuff right here people there you go
left [ __ ] to the body from Canelo Canelo
throws a jab right now Triple G does two
Jabs right hand over the top from uh
Triple G Canelo double jab right hand
here we go this is what we talking about
there we go left hook from Canelo
they are heating up later on in the
fight this is what we wanted to see
they're in the center of the Ring nobody
hugging nobody squeezing up a cut from
Canelo Canelo try to throw a right hand
over the top the nice jab stepped in
nice left hook
come on work him Canelo let's go Triple
G walks over to the left misses wide to
the body shot Canelo steps back throws a
nice jab to the face digs him to the
body oh I think that body shot hurt him
oh left hook all right
there we go Triple G steps over pushes
uh-huh yeah yeah Canelo is definitely
want to go to the body Triple G is bent
over hunched over right hand left hook
here we go Canelo Jabs him back
here we go slow down they slowing down
they hugging right now there's a lot of
activity in that last seconds of those
rounds
here we go back in the center to the
ring
nice Jab
back in the center of the ring uh Triple
G with a jab
Canelo they hugging again they hugging
again they tired they tired
here we go
come on come on get back get back to
that mode where y'all was exchanging
left hook from Triple G left hook from
Canelo oh Canelo tries to uppercut on
the inside
try to take his head off we got 30
seconds left in the round
all right Triple G throws the left hook
inside nice and tight
another left hook uppercut oh he caught
Canelo with a smooth uppercut he tried
to catch him with a right hand nice jab
oh beautiful jab oh Canelo throws a
right hand right down the pipe
he pitched he looked like Randy Johnson
when he threw that right hand oh wait
fantastic stuff Canelo throws the double
jab that's the new joint ooh short right
hand in close Canelo oh beautiful stuff
to hit heads and the round is over that
was phenomenal
that those first two minutes were
phenomenal
oh that's what I'm talking about this is
what I came to see but they gave it to
us too late I wanted to see this from
round one I didn't want to see it around
10. put a zero on that made it a ten not
a one that sucks I don't like it
[Laughter]
I said Jim's hugging
you got a lot of control
come on Canelo you got two more rounds
in you baby give me two more rounds like
that round that you just gave let's go
this was some sweet stuff right here
boom straight right I mean straight job
from Triple G landed three of them
but the problem is his whole go-to is
the Jab
we would wish that his go-to was the
left hook right all right so we went to
the championship rounds round 11 let's
go
all right
oh
so all right then the center of the Ring
Triple G is going for it canelo's going
for it they're right back at it very
furious with these punches they're
jabbing high jab and right hook left
hand from Canelo
oh uppercut right through the middle
from Canelo
straight jab from Triple G
now they grabbing they're hugging each
other get off of me don't hug me baby
let's go back at it
throw the nice job there we go come on
come on back at it Canelo throws over
hand right he misses right now Canelo
Triple G back with the jab back to
posturing let's go Canelo wants to land
that overhand right but Triple G keeps
stepping out of the way he's not there
receive the mail oh uppercut from Triple
G upper cup from uh Canelo
looks like trip uh Canelo has a cut over
his eye uppercut from uh Canelo tries to
throw a right hand right over the top
left hook from Triple G left hook from
Canelo
they go on Tit for Tat folks uppercut
from Triple G
let's go
all right there we go come on let's go
all right
back in the sanitary ring nobody
throwing nothing yet Triple G looks like
he have motion but he's he's stalking
him
but he's not throwing the punch he's not
throwing a punch
jabbing he's jabbing a lot of posturing
no punches being thrown a lot of
posturing no punches and they stop
canelo's trying to catch him in between
shots with a left hook
back to jab from Triple G and Canelo
goes back to a fake of a uppercut
all right
and Triple G goes back to a jab
and they're hugging again
they start off really well
here we go
all right left hook both in the center
of the Ring left hook
Triple G throws a left hook
right hand
left hook right hand and a hug
again
Triple G left hook
Canelo steps forward
Triple G
back up
and he throws an uppercut left hook
Canelo throws a double jab right hand
and again
round 12.
told you I didn't see any knockdowns
coming
no Knockouts had hope for it hope they
had they were going to sell out
um only thing they sold out was the
arena
uh these two dudes
should never fight again
they should never fight again
never ever lacing up again
it's it's it's it's
it's set it's sad because if he would
have fought like this from the beginning
we would have got an outcome that we
could all be comfortable with but unless
there's a knockout or a knockdown within
this round which I don't see or I don't
predict or I don't think it's gonna
happen then we're going to to a 12 round
decision where Canelo is going to win
all right so
do I want to knock out do I want them to
to give us somebody got to go out on
their Shield
excuse me
I'm back in the center of the Ring
Triple G comes back out and he goes for
it Canelo throws it overhand right
Triple G oh smooth left hook from Canelo
sent to the ring these guys are fighting
in the center of the Ring that's right
that's what I'm talking about overhand
right from Canelo uppercut they go to
grab and the referee has to separate
them separate them let's go let's go get
out the ring get out the way there we go
left hook from uh from Canelo oh
uppercut from Triple G all right
separate them separate them separate
them let's go get out the way let's go
come on come on back at the fight oh one
two three from Canelo they back to
hugging come on come on stop it stop
wasting time fight
jab from Triple G
canelo's pushing canelo's pushing
all right
all right there we go get them all from
you push them off that's right
make them fight push them off push them
off push them off come on separate them
man come on man you don't get to the
last round and start the hug let's go
oh good body shot from Canelo good right
hand from Triple G separate them
be fast on the separation come on ref
oh left hook
Triple G
live [ __ ] Canelo left hook trying to go
for a right hand
right there in the center of the Ring
oh
pushing it back to squeezing each other
in the center of the ring this is not
what I wanted to see this is not what
I'm about oh one two from Canelo that
was nice he leaned in according with a
left hook right hand all right separate
those two there we go back into the
fight let's go jab from Triple G left
hook from Canelo and they're falling
into a clinch after clinch after clinch
and they really this is this sucks this
sucks oh left hook from uh Triple G
throw the freaking punches right hand
let's go
everything is on punches right now
because you're tired let's go but fight
though but fight
back to clinch and separate them
you gotta warn them man you gotta stop
this man
right hand there we go left hook right
hand that back declension canelo's doing
the majority of the clinching here he's
tired he can carry the fight the whole
damn night and Triple G is is trying to
come on but he doesn't want to fight
because he goes right into a clinch as
well he separates them 30 seconds left
all right
here we go
back into the center to the ring one two
from Canelo I mean from Triple G back
into a clinch this is the most
anti-climactic last round that you ever
see left hook from Canelo they're gonna
fight at the last 10 seconds of the
round right yeah
fight is over
uh
You Gotta Give the fight to Canelo
that was so weak I didn't even finish my
drink
um
they made some more money
Triple G
showed absolutely nothing he was better
in the first fight he was better in the
second fight he was completely out of it
in this fight he did not have any of
that zip any of that Pizzazz any of that
nothing he didn't have anything
um in my opinion
uh you know he gave some
and what was it the last three or four
rounds he fought the first uh two
minutes of those last rounds and and and
sputtered out at the end
um
then there's no other outcome but Canelo
winning there's no other outcome and if
there's another outcome other than
Canelo winning it's bogus but um yeah I
don't I don't cap for Canelo like that
but there's no other outcome but Canelo
winner I would love to see Canelo versus
David benavidez I would love to see
Canelo versus a Charlo I think um they
will fight all the way through I think
never David benavidez will fight all the
way through I think Jamal Charlo will
fight I I think Andrade would fight I
think these guys would fight all the way
through so
um
you know if uh Triple G fights any of
those guys I think he he gets knocked
out because uh as much as Canelo was
fighting Canelo didn't want to you know
overextend himself uh too much because
for the last two rounds the majority of
the clinching you got to say was done by
Canelo but again Canelo did the majority
of the worker the whole damn fight so of
course he's gonna be tied
let me see
he royally blew it
you said Charlo what Charlo gets cooked
by Canelo any day that you want to come
to the screen this this stream when uh
Canelo fights uh Charlo which he won't
ever do but any day that happens
whatever you want you put your knees up
right there and I Want A Sign Sealed
video of your knees you out of your mind
you said both
don't have a G man you are out of your
mind
out of your mind
but again
this was cool
it was decent
it was
all Canelo
much respect due to Canelo much respect
do it was a beautiful uh
display
of of of his powers
yeah
yeah
yeah
so Canelo one beautiful
you know there's nothing more that needs
to be said that was absolutely
um
your father time walked in on him
tapped him on the shoulder and said you
ready to go
we out of here
they they made money together
that's what they did they made money
together
and all I can say is God bless
so fantastic stuff people
this stuff I love I love so much
I want to thank every last people every
last one of y'all for coming out hanging
out with uh
King the professional fan easy money why
didn't Triple G bring the energy early I
have absolutely no idea
I have no idea
but we have a lot of fights coming up
this week we have Shakur Stevenson
that's fighting this week
um and then we have you know more fights
this month uh I mean next month coming
up so we all just gotta Buckle in and
get ready for that stuff but let me let
you go and let me let you go out with
that that uh that ain't
good
[Music]
as tonight
's off can't talk heavy with a light
show might win might lose or my drug
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I
did
like a tire swerve out here acting bad
thank you Michael Jackson even got his
one and only homie Kevin you a phony
homie now you owe me action happens
and they all wanna talk for attention
but the fame only lasts for instant mama
got handsome bread for the pension imma
leave them red you can dance to
Redemption
[Music]